One of the problems I run into when
talking to people about symbolism
is the whole problem of the "literal versus
metaphor idea" - and I've talked about this
a little bit before -; I want
to dive into that problem and show you
that, in fact, it isn't very
much of a problem once you realize that
there is no such thing as literal.
(Opening) This is Jonathan Pageau,
welcome to "The Symbolic World".
I already hear a bunch of
people screaming:
"No! He's saying that
the Bible didn't happen!";
"He is saying that everything
is just a metaphor!";
not exactly: I'm trying to break that
duality - I'm really trying to destroy it -
because it is really not useful in
understanding how meaning occurs and
how things manifest themselves.
When I say that "there's no such thing as
literal", what I mean by "literal" is this
strange pervasive idea - that is still
there in the West, it seems - that there is
such a thing as a "direct description of
something", that there is such a thing as
a description of something which is not
bound up in meaning and which is not
bound up in narrative, or in an image; that
it is somehow a "meaningless description"...
...which is not already imbibed in meaning.
You get that all the time,
when you talk to people...
...In terms of a story,
in terms of the Bible, especially,
people will argue over whether or not
the description in the Bible are "literal".
To be honest with you, at this
point in my life, at this point in my
understanding, I don't see what that
even means; I can understand - in the
way that people talk about it - what it is
that they seem to be inferring: that it is
somehow a "neutral description" of reality
that doesn't already have value,
or meaning in it, but I don't
understand how that is possible;
because when you describe something, no
matter what it is that you describe, you have
to have a purpose to describe it:
you need a "frame" in order to talk
about something;
like I've told you a million times before,
reality is too big - there are too many
details in it -, and if I describe a series
of events, I will do it with a purpose,
to make you understand something;
I have to focus my attention on something,
because around the event that I'm describing
there are a million other events going on
that I'm not describing, and the question is:
"why am I describing these events
and not describing these other events"?
Already, that harms the problem of this
notion of literal - because if...
...if I am telling a story about something,
and I'm not talking about
the folds in their shirt, or about
the fact that they cut themselves shaving
in the morning, I'm not talking about
those things because they're not relevant to
what it is that I'm trying to get to;
they're not part of the purpose
for which I'm describing something.
Depending on the purpose for which
I'm describing something, I will use
different types of language to describe it -
and the idea that somehow "accuracy",
in this kind of "scientific sense",
is somehow always desirable
is of course completely wrong;
it is completely absurd
because accuracy can also fall
into an indefinite amount of detail.
Let's say that I am describing a fight
and I want you to understand what happened.
I could use a language that is extremely
accurate and say something like:
"The guy put his left foot in front
of his front foot; and then the other
"person's right hand came at this speed
towards his face, and he slightly flinched
"when the fist hit his face: he displaced
so many hairs and displaced so many pores -
"so many tissues in his cheek
were disturbed;
"and then his head moved three
centimeters to the left, and then it
moved forward four centimeters backwards".
I can go on and on, and I could describe
extremely accurately the event, but,
as I'm describing it accurately,
I'm not getting to the purpose that
I'm describing the event for,
that I'm describing this event to you for.
I could say something like:
"the guy got smashed";
"he got his ass kicked";
I could use all this hyperbolic language in
order to help you understand what happened
in the fight, and in the end my hyperbolic
language - the fact that I'll use...
...exaggerations, that I'll use figures of
speech, that I'll use all these different...
...ways of talking about reality - will end
up being truer to the purpose, that I'm
using to describe the event, than if I
was accurate in describing it.
That's extremely important to understand,
especially if we're looking at stories
in the Bible; ...
...each book in the Bible has
different ways of describing things
which are based on the purpose that they
are being described for - and so there are
different styles, different ways, there
are different analogies which can be
used in order to help you understand the
reason for which a text is being described.
Therefore, this idea that you can somehow
get to this "literal description
of reality" is extremely problematic and
it's not useful: it's better to rather
understand the purpose
for which a story is being told.
Even a scientific theory is never
literal -  in the sense of a neutral
description of reality -:
when you do a scientific experiment,
you have to frame that scientific experiment
extremely narrowly, because, like I said,
there are too many details; if
my purpose in a scientific experiment is
to prove something about water, I will
not give you descriptions of trees or
descriptions of rocks: I will talk
about the fact, the thing that I'm trying
to describe; and as a result, that frame will
be extremely narrow and I will use a
certain type of language, quantifiable
language, in order to describe the
phenomena that I'm explaining to you.
The purpose is that you can
understand the mechanistic causes
that bring it about - and, knowing that,
maybe reproduce it mechanistically -;
but, when we're telling or when we're
describing an event, that's not always
the reason why we're describing it;
like I said: using figures of speech can
sometimes be more effective
and more powerful than using just
this kind of quantifiable language.
If I use figures of speech
or if I use analogies to describe
something, does it mean that I'm not
describing an event? Of course not!
Of course I can still be describing
an event, despite the fact that I'm using
different types of ways of explaining it.
The stretch that I'm asking you to make
is very important: the Christian way of
describing reality is that
the world is made by "Logos" - the world
is made by meaning and purpose -;
the very cosmology in which Christianity
exists excludes the idea that there could
be some kind of "neutral reality" that
exists at the bottom somehow,
and that is not informed with meaning
by Logos - the Bible itself describes the
creation process as a process which is full
of meaning and purpose -;
therefore, I don't understand how,
despite that, people can somehow still
have this weird idea of this neutral
reality which exists underneath.
The world of Christianity is a
meeting of Heaven and Earth, it's
a meeting of patterns, Logos, meaning,
purpose and this "potentiality" which
is there at the bottom - maybe
you don't like the word
"potentiality", you can use another word -:
St. Maximus talks about Logos and "Tropos" -
that is this notion of purpose and
meaning, and then the particularities of
something -, and those two have to join
together, and you could call it a
"mini-incarnation" - it's not an incarnation
in the same way that Christ is incarnated,
but it is analogous to the Incarnation,
in the sense that it's an invisible meaning
and purpose which join a kind of
"indefinite particularity"-;
and that meaning together is
where reality exists:
that's where the world, where life
where all of these things are -
and once that starts to break
in our thinking, a lot of things become
less problematic, a lot of things become
less difficult to deal with.
One of the problems that we have is that
people seem to want - let's say
they're reading the story in Genesis,
they're reading the description of
Creation - they want to get to this event:
they somehow think that they can access
this neutral event which is behind the
story - you don't have access to that,
you can't get to it because it doesn't
exist, it doesn't exist on its own -;
the events that happen, as far
as they are described, are this "framing",
this coming together of meaning
and particulars.
What we have is the story.
Especially when we're talking
about something like the Creation story
or the ancient stories that have been
around for thousands of years, what we have
is the story:
to try to somehow get to what
is behind the story in this neutral manner
is not the right way to go;
people do think that, somehow, they can
try - through these archaeological
methods or through these historical
methods - to get to what is
behind the story in Genesis,
but it's a futile trip;
and it's especially futile if you think that,
once you get there, that what you're going to
get ... - from using archaeological methods
or using these different new scientific
ways of breaking down the text into all
these different sources, or
whatever people come up with in the modern
world - ... you're not going to get to
something which is truer than
what the story is offering you;
and once you understand that, then
a lot of things are going to free
up in your mind, and a lot of problems
are going to go away.
One of the examples that
I like to use is the
example of the prophecy that Elijah is
going to come before the Messiah -
there's this prophecy, which is in the Old
Testament, which said that Elijah is
going to come back, that he is going to
show himself before the Messiah.
Therefore, when Christ is there and His
disciples ask Him about this prophecy, ...
...and Christ tells them that "Saint John
the Baptist is the Elijah that was to come
before the Messiah", and He says "if you're
able to receive this,
that is what happened", ...
...if the question is posed: "did Elijah
come before the Messiah?", the answer is
"yes, Elijah did come before the Messiah,
and that Elijah was St. John the Baptist".
Do you see what I'm doing there?
I'm not trying to get to this weird
"literal-neutral reality" behind it:
I'm trying to show you how Christ can
quite easily take this prophecy and show that
it's actually a pattern of reality which
is manifesting itself - and here is the
manner in which it manifested itself, with
Elijah as this pattern, and St. John the
Baptist, with those two coming together;
and so the answer to "did Elijah manifest
himself before the Messiah" is "yes".
That is the answer that I will give
to everything:
-"Did Adam and Eve fall in the garden?"
-"Yes";
-"Did Adam and Eve eat the apple
in the garden?" -"Yes";
I have no problem saying that all of these
things are true and that they are the best
description of that event, and the best
description of that reality;
I'm not trying to get, in some
weird scientific sense, behind the story
to find out what it is that "really
happened" - I don't know what you're
talking about when you say this,
I have no idea what it is that you
think you're going to get to -;
that story is the story that was
given to us as the description
of this extremely important event, and
the question of how to describe that story:
that's it, that's the story, that's the
story we have, and that's the best way to
describe that event.
As I have already said, a lot of the
problems and a lot of the difficulties that
modern Christians have come from the fact
that, without even knowing it,
they have completely taken upon themselves
the kind of "modern scientific
view of the world"
as being the highest reality.
When I was younger, I remember hearing
a Protestant tell me that "science is just
the mind of God" - well, it's a serious
problem to engage the world that way, ...
...because, then, you always end up trying
to get behind the story and to find
some scientific description there -:
well, that description is not there
because science is not the first
degree of reality;
science is great, it's fine, as
I've always told you, to
fly airplanes and to make medicine - for
that purpose, it is wonderful, and it works,
and it does what it's supposed to do -,
but that is not the only way
to describe reality,
and it is not the best way to describe
reality, if your purpose is to show people
how to live; if your purpose is to help
people understand events that happened
so long ago...
...that you won't even
be able to connect to the reference
points in the scientific way, then we use
story tropes - manners of describing
that are the best way to
describe that event.
Consequently, it is
extremely problematic to say that...
...there is this weird opposition
between literal and metaphorical.
There are other people
who somehow think that the metaphor is
going to save them as well, that,
somehow, saying that "something is a
metaphor" is going to get them
out of trouble.
This is particularly true of
Communion.
I've seen this happen so many times
in YouTube comments, people bringing
this up when I talk about Communion,
and I talk about the reality of Communion
and the fact that...
...this is truly
the Body and Blood of Christ -
obviously someone
will show up and say: "No, it's not.
"It's so disturbing to say that because
this is a weird cannibalistic thing.
"It's just a symbol, it's just
a metaphor; Christ is saying that this
is a metaphor for His Body and Blood"; ...
...and because of that, somehow, they think
they're getting out of the problem.
Well, you're not getting out of the problem.
First of all, I will not accord to you
when you say that "it is just
a metaphor", ...
...but let's say that I did -
let's say that I gave that to you, let's say
that I gave the fact that
"it's just a metaphor" to you -:
how are you getting out
of the problem?
You're saying that this idea
is very disturbing,
that we would eat the
Real Body and Blood of Christ;
but do you not think that
it would be disturbing to
eat the "metaphorical body and
blood" of Christ as well?
Why is that not as weird and as
disturbing as saying that it's real?
I'm gonna be a bit disturbing
right now, but let's say that some
weird cult came up with a ritual where
they eat the feces of someone, ...
...or where they have a kind of "inverse
satanic communion" where they
eat the feces of their
master or whatever else;
and then someone from this cult could say:
"Oh, no. We're not 'really' eating
the feces of our master,
"it's just a 'metaphorical eating'
of the feces - we just make this bread
in the form of feces and then we eat it".
Why would that be less weird?
Why is that less disturbing?
Why is that less of a problem?
It's the best for you to deal with the
the mystery -
you can't totally deal with it -,
but it's best to face the mystery
of Communion rather than try to skirt
around it; it's better than to avoid it
by saying that, somehow, because you think
that something is "just a metaphor",
that it is meaningless: it's not!
I keep joking around with this idea -
my brother and I, we always say that
"there's no such thing as literal and
there is no metaphor" -;
that's not how things work,
it's not that simple -
you can't just throw
something away and say:
"That's just a metaphor" -;
well, there's a reason
why you're using that metaphor -
even if it's "just a metaphor" -,
there's a reason why you're...
...using those words and that
purpose, even if it's "just literal" -
these terms are not useful
to help us understand how
meaning occurs and how things unfold.
In terms of Communion, to understand
this problem of the Body and Blood,
not to understand it,
but to deal with this problem -
and to deal with
the idea that it's neither
literal, in the scientific sense,
nor is it a metaphor, in the...
...modern way of understanding a metaphor,
that it is something that is symbolic,
in the way that I'm trying to explain -
this is something which is, by the
bringing together of elements,
and just joining with a spiritual essence,
the way that reality functions.
You could get to the same idea, to the same
understanding, for example, when we say that
"The Church is the Body of Christ":
is that "literal" or is
that a "metaphor"?
It's neither of those: it's
not literal and it's not a metaphor,
it's a symbolic truth - it's
a symbolic truth which can help you
understand what a body is, and
how a body comes together and manifests
something which is above it, how it
manifests something spiritual; ...
...anything that is a body
is always an accumulation of parts,
and just because you visually see those
parts close together in your perception,
does it mean that they aren't parts
which are also separate from each other?
In your body, there's a lot of space between
your molecules, and if you think that
that relative amount of space between
your molecules is not bothersome,
but the bigger amount of space
between the members of The Church
is a problem - so now that can't
be a body -, that's a wrong thought!
Yes, that can be a body: an accumulation
of people can also be a body, just like the
accumulation of your molecules can also
be a body - and the way that that happens
is neither literal nor is it a metaphor.
It is symbolic, ...
...it is the unity of multiplicity which
appears to us and which shows us
the spiritual essence, the Logos,
the purpose which makes us
engage with something as one, as a unity.
I hope that that's a little
bit helpful in understanding why,
if you engage with me with
those types of languages of
literal and metaphorical, why all
of that is not useful to help you
understand the world.
I hope this has helped,
and I will get to talk with
you again very soon.
If you enjoy The Symbolic World content,
there's a lot of things you can do
to help us out: if you are
not subscribed, please do;
go ahead and share this to
all your friends,
if you can get involved in the discussion;
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects - I will put
all those links in the description -; and
also, if you can, please support us
financially by going to my website
www.thesymbolicworld.com/support  ;
I also have a Patreon and a SubscribeStar.
Thanks again, I'll see you soon.